all right we got will
here we go will what's oh let's go
new camera
yeah man i'm not fooling around all
right let's uh let's jump into uh on
chain metrics what do you got for us
this week
sure so this week i actually had uh
our good friend uh nick batia featured
so it's a little shorter than usual
because we actually like hit the limit
on the newsletter for sub stack but
so first off we have um our urpd chart
that we like to we like to look at
pretty often uh this is basically just
on chain volume um and so what you see
here is that we have like four pretty
distinct clusters um the first is like
kind of the pre-bull market cluster
between like 3k and call it uh 11k we
have one while we were consolidating you
know in that little mini bear market
whatever you want to call it between may
and mid july um and that that cluster is
between 30k and 40k obviously
we have the one we're currently in which
is between 44k 50k
and then lastly we have a smaller
cluster above us this is kind of like
the last um zone of resistance i would
say
between 53k and 60k and so we actually
got rejected last week off of um the you
know the the beginning portion of of
that upper cluster
and so on
on this right here how should people
think about these clusters like what
does that tell you when you look and
identify them
yeah so like one way to think about it
is like this is where um mark
participants kind of built up their cost
basis right so like you'll see that the
gray line um the gray bar that just
means like that's where we are currently
that as you can see like that's the
largest bar of volume since like uh like
nine and a half k um like all the way on
the left-hand side of the chart so
that's just showing like there's a lot
of capital inflows at these price levels
there are also a lot of capital inflows
between 30 and 40 k
and so
to me this is showing you know
you can kind of identify like support
resistance areas where
people bought in right because
you know when we come back and re when
we retested you know the the this uh
cluster on the right hand side and we
retested 53k last week you know that
that's where a lot of people have bought
in so obviously there's going to be
overhead supply and this is like
essentially like when you're mapping
resistance levels it's very similar to
the premise for technical analysis just
saying like there's people that bought
in here so once price gets back up to
that level like natural market
psychology says people are going to take
profits that held all the way down
they're like okay well got it back up to
my cost basis i'm i'm getting out of
here so um i don't think it's like super
surprising to see some some you know
rejection off of that initial test of
that um but that's the way i think of it
it's just this is kind of where capital
inflows came in at different levels
got it and then what about supply shock
ratios it looks like we're continuing
the same trend
yeah just seeing real just pretty much
just continuation here we're kind of
started this next impulse i guess you
could call it um as you'll see in the
liquid supply shock ratio
this is essentially just tracking
movement of coins from weak to strong
hands
and this is defined as like entities
based off of their spending behavior
and so liquid entities take in a lot of
coins don't move many now highly liquid
and liquid entities are moving coins in
and out all day wrong right so you're
tracking the movement of coins from um
those those entities that are moving
coins and out all day to those um strong
hands or long-term investors however you
want to think about that um this is also
like the metric that pop i remember back
down in in you know like mid-may or
early june when we were talking about
this bullish divergence and people were
calling us crazy uh but this was like
one of the main metrics that we kind of
used to call the reversal down there
and so as you'll see we had like two
impulses one kind of right above where
it says june 28th one above july 26th
and then recently we've just got this uh
third kind of impulse where we just
moved up actually yesterday as well but
i'm watching to see if we get follow
through i'm suspecting that that'll
probably play out over the next couple
weeks
but also you're seeing an uptick in the
red line it looks like it's smaller it's
just because to be honest i put it on
the wrong scale but it's it's of the
same magnitude as the blue one um this
is tracking the movement of coins from
the highly liquid entities so these are
the people that are like really in and
out of them in and out of the market all
day long right a lot of this is probably
market makers um and then the movement
of of coins from those entities to what
i consider more like the short-term
investors right these are the people
that are um that sell less than uh
or sell more than 50 percent of the
coins that they take in um and highly
liquid by the way is they they sell over
75 percent of the coins they take in
illiquid is less than 25
um so you're seeing the movement of
coins in this red line from those highly
liquid enemies to liquid and then you
want to see that translate into blue
right so you want to see coins go from
highly liquid to liquid and then move
into a liquid and so you are starting to
see um what looks like some translation
from
the the red you know seeing that uptick
and so what that's just saying is that
the coins are moving from liquid uh i'm
using i'm sorry jesus from highly liquid
to liquid uh to a liquid so that's a
good sign and then we have our purple
line uh this is the exchange supply
shock ratio so what you're looking at
here is um a lot of people get this
misconstrued this isn't the percentage
of overall circulating supply that you
know is is exchange balances
this is subtracting
exchange balances from circulating
supply so you're getting the amount of
supply that aren't on exchanges and then
you're running a ratio of that to the
amount of coins that are on exchanges so
essentially similar to
our liquid supply shock ratio right
which is measuring weak to strong hands
here you're measuring the amount of
coins that are available to be bought on
exchanges to the amount of coins that
you can buy and so like seeing this
uptick is basically just another way to
look at the fact that coins are moving
off exchanges and the last week we have
26
150 roughly it's 148 if you want to be
exact of coins that moved off exchanges
totaling uh roughly 1.25 billion dollars
at a 48 000 bitcoin uh price so
you're starting to see continued coins
mobile exchanges coins are moving to
these uh you know longer term investors
which is of course a good sign uh and i
mean this this has been pretty much up
only since since kind of mid-may right
so when you look at the whales you take
people who've got more than a thousand
bitcoin and you take out the exchanges
people that we know have the exchange
wallets uh it looks like the whales are
going absolute bonkers and buying
bitcoin right now uh and soaking up
whatever they can buy
yeah like so if you look at this if i i
know in the in the uh chart i put in
there that you have up on the screen
it's kind of zoomed in but if you go
back to like mid-may um whales did a lot
of the selling on the way down um i
think a lot of that this is a whole side
thing but i think a lot of that had to
do with like some arbitrage
opportunities that closed um because
that kind of aligned with where we saw
um the number of whales and whales
holdings drop off but yeah since like
mid late uh july you started to see
whales you know pretty aggressively
buying um and as you mentioned like what
we're looking at here is all the
entities um so this is forensically
clustered addresses which are what
entities are um and then you're
filtering out as you said exchanges and
then also like grayscale the purpose uh
etf also qbtc um and so you're just
basically getting the raw uh
you know whale balance and so what you
see here is that um since july 17th
which is uh two months ago whales have
added 184 699 btc which is roughly 8.8
billion dollars once again using that
forty eight thousand uh dollar bitcoin
as that's the reference for that
when you look at the asol it remind
everyone what asol ends up actually
being and how you look at this and then
what is this chart telling us
yeah so
what we're looking at here is we're
trying to track the age of the coins
that are moving and so there's a couple
ways you can look at this i just decided
to throw an asole because i hadn't put
that chart in the newsletter for a while
um but you want to kind of use all these
metrics in tandem so um for example we
have like our spin output age bands uh
are spent volume age bands coin dates
destroyed dormancy liveliness and each
of these different metrics have a
different purpose so for example like a
sol is just the average of all the spent
um outputs on a given day but there's no
weight given to it by volume so you know
if if you have what appears to be high
spending from older coins um you you
need to also look at the volume of which
they're selling because if they're
selling like .001 btc no who cares right
but if you're seeing the volume of of um
and that's where you look at the spent
volume age bands um and also you can
look at like 20 days destroyed um you
can see the volume of um older coins is
perhaps increasing or decreasing and
then look at is is that in correlation
with um like the the acell or your spent
output age bands which are literally
just looking at the average uh or uh the
average in case of acehole but also
spent output age bands you're just
looking at the amount of spent outputs
on a given day so you know nuance
yada yada yada but it's just saying you
need to use these different age-related
metrics in tandem
but overall the conclusion here is um
just the fact that long-term holders are
sitting tight right we're seeing
declining in in the age of the coins
that are being spent on each you know on
on every given day over the last week or
so
and so you see that in tandem across you
know across the board and all these
age-related spending metrics and that's
just the kind of point i was trying to
get out here so a lot of the spending is
coming from these younger coins
got it and when you look at the futures
market i know that there was a bunch of
futures and derivatives that played into
some of the price movements previously
what are you seeing right now in the
futures market
yeah so you know on-chain is obviously
like
it tracks broader trends right and so
for these kind of short-term price
fluctuations um obviously you need to
watch a like short-term price structure
but also derivatives data um and so last
week we got a complete flush in the
derivatives market we had you know this
massive
you know liquidation cascade
since then we started to see a recovery
in funding and then also in futures open
interest
so futures open interest has recovered
by roughly a billion dollars from the
wipeout but it's still three billion
dollars from where it was at before we
had the selloff last week
and then also funding is slightly
recovered but it's still pretty far from
where we were at um you know leading up
to that that cascade last week so you
know keeping an eye on some of the on
some of the stuff like you can just
watch basic you know just watch funding
in futures you know open interest and if
you see like a large increase in both of
those um you know perhaps that's that's
the time to to be a little more cautious
in the short term right um but you know
the i think like and this this kind of
goes into the next chart the broader on
change structure in my in my opinion
like when looking at these supply
dynamics when you have things like you
know supply that hasn't moved in at
least a month hitting hitting an
all-time high at 93 percent of supply
has moved in you know at least a month
you have long-term holders supply
hitting an all-time high a lot of these
things are are just in my opinion
undeniably bullish for the coming months
but perhaps you know on the on the
shorter term time frames you know you
can get these liquidation driven moves
um because you know
the liquidity in the futures market is
massive um so it has it has a large
impact on on pricing short term
when you think about um the current
state that we're in i think over the
last couple of weeks we've really talked
about this kind of uh supply squeeze it
seems like about 90 of bitcoin hasn't
moved in the last 30 days or so only the
uh earliest youngest coins are being
sold the whales are buying up as much
bitcoin as they possibly can is this
just a recreation of a lot of the market
dynamics from october of 2020 which then
was followed by like a 500 move do you
see a lot of similarities between those
two things
yeah for sure like you know i think like
a lot of the metrics that
like i'm looking at they kind of
resemble the end of like a a bear market
almost um and so like my kind of like
framework for the current like where we
are right now is kind of that we're
transitioning out of like the latter
half of like a bare phase for the market
um but you know like zooming out it kind
of appears some things are you know
saying that we're kind of in like the
middle of a bull market so i guess the
way i would frame it is that we just
came out of a mini bear phase within a
broader bull market structure um but
a lot of the things when you're talking
about the spy dynamics as you just
mentioned are in fact like resembling
kind of mid to late um you know 20 20. i
like that joe john what questions you
guys got what's going on will appreciate
you coming out man um i got a quick one
about hash rate so we saw it fell about
50 to 55 earlier this year uh with
everything going on it's recovered uh
aggressively since then we're probably
about halfway back so uh maybe 20 to 30
percent uh down from its all-time highs
but how do you think about bitcoin's
hash rate uh in terms of future price
um
[Music]
i guess the way i would think about it
is just um you know as as more hash
comes on the network like minor
profitability goes down right like when
hash first came off the network like
north american miners were super
profitable um
because there was less competition for
the same amount of
block reward right and so as hash has
come back on the network that
profitability has not in a big way but
it's it's started to get more
constrained right as you start to see it
recover um and so i would suspect like
you're gonna see some some uh you know
like marginal selling from these miners
perhaps as as they need to cover their
cap capex but like at the same time
you know now they have you know so much
access to the capital markets they can
just raise capital to you know uh cover
their their operational costs so
um
it's it's i don't know it's hard to say
because part of me thinks
they're gonna have to sell some of their
btc and miners have been selling over
the last call at two weeks because you
know their profit their profitability is
getting a bit constrained as hash
continues to come back in the network
but at the same time we know like miners
now can just borrow you know as much
capital as they need uh and they can tap
into the capital markets that way so
i don't know man like it's it's hard to
say i those are kind of like my two
arguments though for and against if it
has a positive or negative effect gotcha
john yeah well what's up thank you for
doing this we all know you're big time
now so
so i have uh i have two questions one
can you just talk about kind of the
resistance that bitcoin has i read the
other day that people were kind of
calling the resistance at 46 000. um and
then also can you talk about so from
february to may of this year it
apparently seemed that a lot of whales
were kind of building short positions
and distributing their long positions uh
to push out retail traders can you talk
about that and if we're seeing what we
saw in february kind of now
sure so like i think on a short term
basis um i kind of look at like
um these levels they're created by a guy
on twitter called spaceman btc so shout
out to him uh but it's looking at like
the weekly high monthly high daily open
monthly open
you know
these like shorter term key levels right
and so um we've broken out above the the
monday's high and also the monthly open
and then we come back down and now we're
re-testing uh the monthly open so
if we can if we can move back off of uh
you know this retest of the monthly open
right now i'm kind of looking at a move
up towards the previous monthly high
which is around 50 55k
um and we're also above the 200a which
is another you know kind of key level
that i think a lot of legacy finance is
probably watching but the key level from
like a technical perspective for me is
watching this point of breakdown which
we we broke down out of in in may
and so that's you know right around 40
49k call it uh because
for me like that's important because
you're showing you know
price price the market is now decided
that it's moving above where it
decisively moved uh you know down into
this mini bear phase in uh in you know
like in mid may so if we can get back
above call it 50k which is also just a
psychological number um that would also
mean we're getting above the previous
monthly high and also the point of
breakdown
and so if we can move back above that
level that would be a really strong sign
for me
but in the in the short term like i'm
watching this retest of the monthly open
see how we react
but i feel pretty confident here also
you know obviously from on chain
perspective um but you know seeing that
we're now sitting above the 200a and
just broke above monday's high and also
um you know we did break above the
monthly open but as i just said we're
not retesting it um but yeah what was it
was the second question
no you're good um does it look like
does this look similar to what we saw in
february so someone mentioned the chat
about how maybe some whales are building
like shorter positions and distributing
their long positions uh to push out
retail traders i'm curious what you
think about that
it's hard to say like
one interesting thing i have been
watching though is like
biffin x like i watch sometimes like the
heat maps of like the bids and asks and
it's interesting like it seems like the
biff and x the large biff and x buyers
almost always get their uh their their
bids filled um so that that's been one
interesting thing and like whenever
their bids get filled you also see like
an uptick in on chain like you know the
whales holdings as well but i don't know
it's hard to like say if they're if
they're like moving the market or not um
but i i guess the only the only thing i
would say is just that seems like whales
are kind of uh getting their spots
picked pretty well and they're they are
getting their bits filled so i don't
know i i think it's like hard to it's
hard to make that conclusion but um you
know i definitely don't think that um
you know it's anything against that
argument that i've been seeing cool well
last uh last question we'll let you go
prediction changing for uh end of year
are we still uh still on track for a big
blow off uh top here
no prediction hasn't changed i don't
know about blow off top though um but
i think perhaps like this run
stretches out into like q1 of next year
um
but yeah like i think the supply
dynamics though from like a macro
perspective are setting up for a really
strong next couple months um obviously
it depends on if we get some catalyst
with you know some announcements or you
know there's been a bunch of chatter
about this supposedly etf announcement
coming out which i'm not an expert on
any of that stuff so we'll we'll see how
that goes but from just like the pure
supply dynamics standpoint i think yeah
we're setting up for uh
an exciting next couple months awesome
man don't have too much fun this weekend
we appreciate you
thanks man you guys take it easy thank
you buddy what's up guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today if we're gonna be
the best business show we obviously need
the best partner that's why the
exclusive sponsor the best business show
is sofi they're an all-in-one platform
that allows you to invest in all kinds
of different assets including stocks
etfs crypto ipos and they even have an
automated investing function if that's
your thing so before we start getting
after it again make sure that you go
download sofi you get an invest account
and when you make your first crypto
trade regardless of what you buy they'll
give you 10 in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]